[Music]
you have 12 hours to commit one crime
and you're not going to get in trouble
for it what is it oh I'm going to oh I
got to steal a cool car you're going to
steal a car yeah a cool car like a
really fast car like vroom vroom it's
zero to to 60 in A5 second I was hoping
you were going to kill somebody but
that's a different story for a different
time it's Benny Veronica someon Louise
it's Teran Roxy we did it we missed
hands but we're talking about the birge
watching The Purge today apparently
that's the premise I've never seen this
movie but I've heard it referenced a
thousand times because people always ask
that it's kind of a common first date
question what who's going on dates with
what who are these people just saying if
you guys were on the dates that I was on
you would have been asked the question
about The Purge before and you would
know exactly what your answer already
was I would have ran out if you like
everything that's going on so far and
you are excited about this video leave a
like a comment let us know how cool you
think we are especially cuz it's spooky
season yeah and don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell I could have set you
up better for that one I knew you were
going to come in with the bell I just
sometimes I can't wait I just like I got
to I Feel It In My Bones yeah and you
guys can't wait either to see more of us
over on patreon with a full length
Reaction watch along where you sink up
with your own copy I didn't look down at
the shape for that
yeah baby she's got it down she's got it
memorized yeah Greg and John are over
there and they cover several shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included are you ready to
purge everything that's gone wrong this
year and jump into the purge emotionally
yeah but for the other stuff not ready
yet that'll be later at home by myself
very good let's watch The Purge
cool
[Music]
spooky music in a world where you can
decide who gets to live and die for 12
hours Terra stole a car yeah I didn't
ask Roxy what she would do but I know
she I guess she would kill people okay
unemployment's at
1% so this must have been filmed before
2022 right and they were hoping that was
going to be very low
crime when is this movie
from they were like crime is super low
in 2022 and we're like yo homies that
was last year and crime was very
[Laughter]
high
oh okay Ethan Hawk didn't know he was in
this also found Foley or Hy or however
you say her name I like her
too this is what happens during The
Purge the juxtoposition of these shots
and this music
is yeah very so much if you just closed
your eyes you would think we were
watching something that you could watch
with your grandparents
yeah the music's by Nathan Whitehead so
you made a choice here I like it I think
I would have made the obvious one and
put like metal music over it but this is
way better system is working without a
hitch you are going to be locked in
tight tonight thank you sir all right Mr
Faulk safe night James office Sue yeah I
took care of folk what do you know do
you hear anything you're number one Mr
sandon you got it sir congrats
congratulations to you too Susan you
don't have to say that no Susan it's a
team win thank you okay all right well
safe night safe night Mr sand between
this and black phone is uh Ethan Hawk
kind of a horror horror guy now right
beat from Northern Virginia what's your
Purge plan I'm going to hunt down my BS
what American streets will be running r
tonight is that why everyone's setting
flowers you getting one last walk in
before lock down huh all right nobody's
bothering us tonight well you have a
safe night Mr Sanders which means
everyone's bothering them tonight do you
think this is a smart idea like the the
the concept of The Purge so that there's
less crime year round because you can
just do it that one day with no
penalty not to make it political I feel
like some people would watch this and
try to implement I'm thinking it through
it might
be until the annual Purge okay not 60
Minutes 62 minutes but they set out the
blue flowers to show their support of it
right we are inherently a violent
species Wars genocide murder the denial
of our true selves is the problem The
Purge not only contains social violence
to a single evening
[Laughter]
Purge that's what you would do all night
anytime I mess with somebody pillow
before say perge bump into
people
ooh Young Love or is it lust probably
lust I love you oh nope it's love that's
what she thinks girl why because
everyone says I love you it's used and
we need to find our own thing go like
this
no do it it's our way to saying I love
you that's fing cute that is cute she
doesn't want to do it cuz she thinks
look silly
okay I love that she did
it I think my dad's
home I'm sorry baby got to get going I'm
sorry and you have to get home before
lockdown why aren't you doing it all
right I bullied you
[Music]
this movie is kind of quirky yeah and it
kind of feels like a home video the way
it's shot a little like I don't know
that it's there's a lot of shaky cam
stuff going on handhelds oh I have a new
hobby Bing I made way too many cookies
Hi O cookies maybe she poison them yeah
why does this something seem off yeah
just what the hon needed more cookies
right
they do she does not like her new
addition you built it's just amazing
that house is sick you know your husband
sold a new security system to almost
every home in this community he's about
to tell her this neighborhood paid for
that new addition on your home it's just
good old neighborhood gossip nothing to
worry about I can't stand her I hope she
dies in The Purge
one we're just going to lock down watch
some Purge events nothing special that's
what I would do that's what I do on New
Year's Eve lock it in watch it on TV
watch some Purge events like yeah
newscasters out recording it even though
it's not illegal it's so
creepy what is this POV the
dog dude maybe it's a cat
Roxy you scared me to death it's just a
drum is it their you can't keep creeping
up on me like that
Charlie oh security nice so quit playing
with Timmy and come help me set the
table kid up now why is he looking at
his mom's legs yeah that that angle is a
little weird little creeper I insted a
night vision program and I insulated his
motor so you can barely hear him and he
can now play music to accompany him on
his
missions terrible
song I don't like it that's really rude
of you I mean you were really dancing to
it I don't know why I kind of D
it
Purge sorry I forgot to take my vitals
earlier by the way there's a slight
deviation in my heart rate but uh other
than that nothing to worry about what I
that kid I didn't all sales are final
and I'm on top my division sold the most
upgraded security systems
congratulations Dad yay
Ethan all right it's time for lock down
let's
go what do you think they do go into a
bunker yeah they have to right in a
basement and then oh God Mr Sabian and
Mr Babar are going hunting that's daring
fens are having a party Grace said she
wasn't having a party this year well
just thank God we weren't invited she's
nice but she's annoying agreed minus a
nice part she makes cookies though so do
I at the front if you brought cookies
I'd like you more R I bring cookies all
the time but Greg doesn't eat eat them
except on the weekend so I'll bring you
cookies I eat them all right let's hit
it what are they hitting exactly like
they they're
Lo okay what is it their whole house
though oh wow oh I guess it's all the
windows or yeah is the security system
that he's selling to other people this
is like stainless steel walls coming
down it must be the the what he sells
that's intense this is your emergency
broadcast system announcing the
commencement of the annual Purge weapons
of class four and lower have been
authorized for use during The Purge wow
government officials of ranking 10 have
been granted immunity from The Purge and
shall not be harmed oh I was wondering
if people try to kill the president yeah
murder will be legal and murder police
fire and Emergency Medical Services will
be unavailable until tomorrow morning at
7:00 a.m. when The Purge concludes
blessed be our new founding fathers and
America Nation reborn what a wild
premise that's insane that's scary I
thought they were just going to like
wander around and like take stuff can I
go now I would prefer to be miserable in
my room of course you may thank you for
being
here who do you think's going to die of
the four of them the teenager girl first
allows people a release for all the
hatred and violence and aggression that
they keep up inside them if your mother
and I were so inclined uh we would
participate because it works I kind of
feel him bro I really do and I'm like
sitting in how real this is right now
going like holy tamolly holy to I think
it's holy Toledo I don't say that
Roxy Hide Away throwing
your her boyfriend okay how do he get
in stainless steel you just was there
the whole time obviously wanted to
surprise you left so I snuck in when you
were eating baby you can't be in here my
dad will lose his mind if he sees you
here now come on aren't you happy to see
me can't leave now they're behind
stainless steel walls so is the purge
really about releasing aggression and
containing violence detractors often
postulate this evening is actually about
the elimination of the poor the needy
the sick those unable to defend
themselves that's so I didn't even think
about that that the elite would go out
they're going out hunting they're
killing the poor on the streets to clean
up the streets you and I are people that
we thought this was a good idea for I
know I I just thought of what Ethan Hawk
was selling and that's what I assumed
like oh yeah you you got rageed like go
break a window and steal a I don't know
steal a candy bar only rich people can
do this dang that's why he said they're
going out hunting that's what I didn't
understand I just said that's crazy
what's wrong with us
terara put us in in the lock us up PC
[Laughter]
prison oh oh he's spying on his sister
and he was into his mom's leg the little
boy's a creeper right here we go oh my
God oh my God I hate if he stops and
looks up his sister's skirt he no I came
to see your father what why it's time to
straighten this out he cannot forbid you
from saying me he thinks you're too old
for me talking to him is only going to
make him more angry he's older than her
he looks younger D yeah he's gonna try
to hurt the dad came to see your father
or maybe he's just like oh this is the
one night that your dad can't leave and
he has to talk to meist I think that's
what he was just implying just then but
that doesn't mean it's
true criminalization of murder for one
night
Purge sorry this is working this is
working this is wild I do think it would
work to lower the crime rates through
through the year
right it just also doesn't like say that
you can't be her and you hate somebody
from high school and you're like I'm
going to go kill her now they sell it as
like rich people killing poor people but
still it's it's wild I thought I heard
gunshots it's probably somebody just
firing off a few rounds before going
hunting I have a feeling the poor people
are going to get together and be like if
they're going to do this to us now we
need to go like take over Beverly Hills
and kill them
all and now supposed to be seeing right
now okay in the
corner what's he seeing this person run
to what that's across the street right
okay what's Happening Here help me
someone please help me oh no it's fake I
feel like that person doesn't need help
and he going to kill the little kid
might try to help him or something I
just need to get some safe anybody hear
me like I won't hurt you no kid somebody
please just open the door for me they're
coming they're coming King somebody
please they going kill
me oh my God come here let's go this
way come on oh no hurry this little kid
is going to be the demise of everybody
he doesn't get get it oh my
god oh no hurry oh no he's going to get
killed my God is he going to get okay
okay oh no the hell's going
on oh no what is going to happen
commercial break I know
right what Mr
sandon James he has it gone Henry has a
gun
holy oh my go hen hen oh God is Zoe I
didn't hit Zoe she's Zoe where's the
other dude who is he why did you let him
in our home he was hurt he called for
help no one was helping we have no idea
what this man is capable of enough James
he's gone he's not gone he's not gone
you're he's in the
house Henry Henry why did you try to
shoot my father yeah exactly like why
aren't you like what in the actual F
dude like you had a
gun he I'm confused why is she is she in
on it or is she like no way what I'll go
out there and I'm going to find Zoe Zoe
doesn't want to be found he didn't shoot
at me I I'll find her so I can
go I can't let you go with that man out
there send the little robot yeah exactly
like that's the one time it would be
useful where is the Little Robot yeah
where'd you leave it
kid Zoe this
me oh dang is he dead yeah I think so I
think he's going to like grab him oh no
somebody's
no check your surroundings
bro yeah like where's the daughter
behind
Charlie you wait here I'm going to be
right outside the door he's definitely
not going to wait there he has a whole
lir really that he wants to get back to
Mom I didn't know him was going to do
that I didn't know he was going to why
would he do that I don't understand why
just give me a second okay momy died
he's dead he's dead mom mom Charlie come
oh God is he Charlie Sees the guy what
Dad I'm sorry where are you going girl
okay zo where is she she going there's
the lack of communication bro this
family's got issues yeah I would grab
her arm and be like you are in this room
you're grounded
oh is that annoying lady yeah they all
the people that are having party they're
coming to the house they're coming to
the house because there there their
Community built the add-on and not
everybody had as good of a year as them
whoa is she okay is she is she she's not
her I I couldn't get her to come with me
feel like she didn't try to get her to
come with you but all leted
slide oh my God tell them what is like
what are we going to do they all the
same security system so they know how
they work exactly and I'm like but what
are they hoping to gain here I'm like he
sold you the system that's keeping you
safe and now you guys are like no maybe
they sent the guy into the house to dis
to
[Music]
get and then they have to be your
neighbors afterwards so awkward we want
to treat you fairly so listen closely
we've gotten gussed up in our most
terrifying guyses as we do every year
but things took a turn our Target
escaped us and uh oh your neighbors
informed us that you the sandon have
inexplicably given him Sanctuary Mr Mrs
the man you're Sheltering is nothing but
a dirty homeless Pig killing one of us
when we attempted to execute him tonight
waa you need to return him to us alive
so that we may Purge as we are entitled
wow that is some tough verbage this
movie is [__] up you have until our
Provisions arrive Provisions which will
help us break into your elegant home if
you don't deliver him by the
aforementioned time we'll release the
beast on him and on you we can enter any
home we want as wanting as our will on
this fine night wow that dialogue is is
great uh we don't want to kill our
own also the shot the angle on his face
he's so menacing Purge her in the
background brilliant we thought it was
the neighbors but it's not wow that was
very very well done and the premise of
this just got so much more interesting
splitting them between the halves and
the Have Nots and like would you give a
poor person up to save your family if
this was your Society disgusting what an
interesting so gross it also brings up
the tough like realization there are
people like that who are like we are
entitled to kill this person because
they are less than what we think the
system it works 99% of the time it looks
good it's strong people stay away is it
impenetrable no nothing's impenetrable
things like this are not supposed to
happen in our neighborhood ooh this is a
classist movie we're going to give them
what they want we have guns and he
doesn't but they'll kill him okay kid I
like you now why should he die it's Dr
that's a but if you're a parent tough
call you just go well this Society is Fu
up bro and it's our society it's pushing
them into like it's you can't it's an
impossible decision either they all die
or they send the one guy out well it's
not that though they don't know that
they're all going to die but they know
if they send him out he's going to die
that they would probably all die an
elitist disgusting movie I did not think
that's what this was going to be I
thought it was going to be like fun
horror movie not like a question on
around yeah exactly like a question on
the societal standards of you give us
the homeless man no will miss him when
he's
gone
please I just thought people were going
to be running around stealing stuff and
we'd see it I don't
know we hear you're like us the
halves oh
oh creepy found footage part two
weird it's not cuz it's their whatever
cams but it looks like that it really
does maybe they should kill them right
yeah I guess they could just kill all of
those people and keep the keep the guy
who wasn't trying to hurt anybody alive
it's a harder task
but I got enough weapons for it
though why are the lights off I missed
that I don't they must have they must
have
lost yeah oh this thing it doesn't make
sense though because then the the TVs
are still on so they still have power
that's their backup generator oh rich
people [__]
yeah is right there
tell him yeah but little kid's trying to
protect him can he talk out of that
thing nobody can listen remember when
the mom was talking to him and it plays
music now remember he showed that it can
play songs yeah terrible song you're so
rude about my favorite
song like what
it is he Morse coding oh cuz he sees the
tags smart yeah oh he's a vet
this movie knows how to get us to like
yeah to get your pull at the
strings is he showing him where to
hide where are
you fire him I'm like what the [__] is
this rich people [__]
right it's super uncomfortable themes
that this is about like poverty race
yeah morals just like in general it's
just making you think everything just
very smart movie so
far oh oh gave him his
lair it's so [__] up that there are so
many homeless veterans
yeah it's weird to highlight the class
system of people who want to go fight
for where you live and they don't they
don't have an opportunity to live very
well once they come back it's like we
can give all the money in the world to
the military but not to the members that
fight for the country and then come back
with nowhere to live Dear Mr sandon
sorry to interrupt but I'd love to have
a word leave by your front door I just
need a moment good sir would you go yeah
a cool shot SLI going to W what there
you are tell me why haven't you
delivered the filthy swine to me yet are
you protecting him no we can't find him
my son let him in but I support what
occurs here tonight 100% just give us
the homeless P you
[__] what I don't condemn that kind of
behavior not civilized pleas keep in
mind Mr sandon he was my friend and you
are not ha who is this actor he's fing
good he's very
good okay okay I don't know what's going
on there there are people outside I'll
be okay I have his gun I'm going to go
hide in your secret
spot okay yep
[Music]
no another good plot moment yeah who
wrote this nice twist it's great
dialogue like I really love and story
they crushed it
Purge are you getting annoyed with it or
no it's no I'm fine with it knew it yeah
cuz he's a veteran he's gonna know we
didn't do anything to you we don't
deserve this I didn't deserve this
either Y and I don't want to hurt any of
you but I am not dying
tonight who's behind him yeah it's the
kid the kid came oh the mom mom the mom
but she can't shoot him she can't so
take that gun away from my daughter's
head shoot it Mary shoot
it
what the what happened I think he threw
the girl yeah he threw her but then
what [__] what what he shot
[Music]
him he then asked for him delivered
alive remember and we have to tie him up
and get him outside and we're going to
end this goddamn night it's just so up
like that they think his life is not as
important as right if they were smart
they would see the tags and say we could
all fight together you have the most
skills in fighting military man let's go
kill these jerk offs outside but then he
puts his kids at risk I understand
everybody's motivation but this okay oh
no she's not going to be okay with it
the tape and tape them in there
oh what oh you got to calm down he's
going to break this t
press on his wound press on his wounds
just trying to protect my
family what calm down oh my
God
me
what oh my gosh stop
again oh oh my goodness like who will
your kids be though if they think that
this is acceptable
behavior you meant like what example are
you guys setting right yeah a terrible
one look what we're doing yeah yeah okay
go
Charlie Charlie baby where'd you go oh
no is he opening the doors don't fing
disarm this [__] again Charlie you
little no there there's no way cuz he
doesn't want to give the guy up yeah but
then that way he thinks I don't know sit
down sit down you hit your head are you
okay I am so sorry about Henry oh no the
guy got loose look at what you're doing
nothing is ever going to be okay again
he is in a tough position but you can't
turn into a monster right you have to do
the right thing or you can't live with
yourself you should have just been like
we have to get rid of these people
together so that you don't die these are
the [__] outside yep and it's risky
save your children take me outside but
give him the weapons that guy is too
good he's too good you better sew him up
give him all your weapons you guys
messed
up what what is this oh it's the oh it's
the
equipment the backup all right the
arrival down oh this is is terrifying oh
my God they're going to that's going to
be five 10 seconds no longer you're not
you're not sending I have another idea
okay you take this gun all right you're
going to go hide in the basement and
you're not going to come out for anybody
all right everybody gets a gun now you
have enough we're going to fight yeah
yeah yeah fight fight fight fight fight
take this y'all better get with it get
with a
plan you're going to use a lot of rounds
what do I do you're going to over the
other side of the house yes you fine
folk should know better that piece of
Filth that you are protecting exists
only to serve our need to purge release
the beast boys let the killing commence
what is the Beast that they keep
referring to the Beast I guess is the
equipment no there's got to be a per I
don't
know it was 5 Seconds that was so
fast yeah they go get military man and
give him a weapon come on daughter bro
what is going on she's old enough to
have a gun and cover the other side of
the house come on that blonde dude
is he's a phenomenal phenomenal actor
yeah I can't believe I haven't seen him
in much since then maybe I have and he
looks different he knows how to play uh
really offsetting very well also all
these other people in masks their agents
did not fight hard for their face to be
seen
yeah oh my God untie him and ask him to
help you why did they not do that makes
me mad this family y'all aren't not
using your brains right I don't
understand
this yeah that's stupid the kid the
little kid's going to give him a gun I
think what's two guns going to
do oh boy and skipping to it huh she
doesn't have a gun she has knives you
brought knives to a gunfight yeah man
she's going to machete your head off and
probably have a lot of fun doing it is
the
problem Oh behind her behind her behind
her behind you [__] behind you God you
should have un undone the military guy I
don't know why you're not asking for his
help right now and being in his little
prep boy outfit I bet he goes to school
with the girl oh he probably does right
cuz the little uniforms yep I cannot see
what he is doing no I couldn't even tell
if it was him no some we're just going
to reach a
person I was right and it happened and I
knew it oh my
god did they get the gun taken oh he's
getting dragged I can't see what's
happening he's getting dragged this
movie is so dark okay dark emotionally
but also
visually yes yes yes Dad all right I
mean of course he's going to check under
the bed kind of a go-to the little lady
s
was sa for me oh that's some oh gross
gross [__] whoa what is it that's a cool
gun lawn mower
oh oh no oh no what is this oh they're
just like okay that's some gross freaky
[__]
wa this is a big weapon but I don't feel
like it has good aim okay come
on kill
her his son needs to come help yeah or
the military guys got to show up and
kill him use the come onuse your come on
now all
right they're like animals disgusting oh
yeah go get that
guy oh ah what is he doing he's using a
pool stick yeah I guess where did what
happened to his
weapon
[Music]
okay so sad to see that pinball game go
but had to be used can I tell you
something yep Ethan Hawk is hot
yeah always has been always will be
Y and now that he's less racist and less
classist in this movie he's he's way
better oh nice good job that's a great
shot who is it does he recognize her
she's on like a class if he goes to look
at the other person and makes that
face I not see that coming your soul has
been cleansed Mr sandon you've purged
was this life really worth yours your
families thank you for this
Unforgettable Purge Mr sandon
ew oh my God he should play The Joker
bro that's what I was going to say him
outside right now absolutely all of his
moves the laughing his face like the
whole
thing what are the don't know why are
there still about to get killed I don't
know they're about to get killed
why oh it's the neighbors that she
didn't like it's the neighbors we didn't
like they came are they saving them like
does that make her a lot less shitty
now also where is the guy and why are
you guys not asking for his
help what don't hesitate why are you
crazy coming out of a wall like that
just
screaming oh nope I don't like it I
don't like it we need the son or the
daughter to show up oh they want the
military remember they want to like
sexually oh they're tickling her oh it
it might have been heard that they
wanted to
save maybe
not okay
oh my
[Music]
God yes oh the neighbors the neighbors
no it's him oh it's the neighbors yeah
oh my God whoa who are the ones who
drove by in the car
yes and what they just leave they came
to help them I know but they weren't
like hey are you good like that was
weird they're just like I don't think
they want to be seen I don't know this
is but why not because then you don't
support The Purge I don't know that
seems like a big thing here with the
blue
flowers Charlie Charlie
sorry how many hours into the purge do
you think we are well the sun's coming
up now that I'm realizing like the
lighting
here oh no all you there in one place
thank you for your
sacrifice you have a lot of heart Mr
Sand where's the daughter where rebor
bed now the
daughter whoa get it girl she came out
from under the bed she's doing some
shooting at least she helps in some way
good
job is he what's going on
cheit
I bet the hospitals the next day are
just 5,000 hour weights oh he's
gone
yeah y'all killed Ethan Hawk we saw that
you were having some trouble we decided
to help you she so what is going on
there's a Twist
here thank you seem just I don't know
what to say don't thank us too much Mary
you're going to kill him the truth is
you're our ours not
theirs what do you mean ours what do you
mean what do you mean ours what what
what maybe the boyfriend's still alive
well the military guy is going to going
to come in yeah yeah yeah forg I've been
waiting on him to kill six people in
under a second why you doing this yeah
thank you why are you doing this right
now you made so much money off of us and
then you just stuck it in our faces I'm
really begging you right now to not do
this to my children this is the first
because ofon
no be founding
fathers oh it's so freaking weird I'll
go first and then oh my God we'll take
turns okay come on buddy where is he oh
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah all right he he
found the
remote
yes that's so satisy drop your weapons
right
now and time let's go he could have just
saved himself but he
didn't kill them all your call your
cough and kill him just get it over with
oh she's going to let them live kill us
quickly okay I guess you're stepping up
weirdo going to kill us it doesn't
matter we are going to play the rest of
this night out in [__] peace get
out of my
house
what
okay so uncomfortable so
awkward what an interesting choice to
end this
with oh my God you better no yes
yes no more killing
tonight that hard to
understand
nice now get the hell out of my house
yeah I was waiting for that line it's
like now you these are your neighbors
right well you guys are going to have to
move like there are consequences to
everybody's actions no matter if there
are no consequences in that moment it's
just like something you gotta live with
that I mean that's
why do I hope he stays and they get
married I know I'm sick something's
wrong with me please say thank you are
you going to be okay thank you
good just after 7 a.m. March 22nd the
actual Purge has just concluded oo wow
the new founding fathers have released
an early statement saying this was the
most successful Purge yet what a creepy
thing over these credits voiceover
literally
I witness a group of young men breaking
into the T next to me and were bloody
stranger Edwin Hodge were killed last
night for their sacrifice to make this
country a safer place it's so weird this
like rooms BR I was wondering if they're
going to be like oh what do the
emergency services do now do they just
clean up dead bodies anouncing in both
sectors profit it's it's weird they're
talking about profits in certain sectors
and like how was the most successful
Purge it's all it's all a lot it seems
like Dallas had the most participants
Dallas for as long and there had to be
200 people in the Town Square purging at
the same time this is the first time
I've ever listened to credits before
yeah me too I'm like I am so curious
this country is taking everything from
me interesting that's a good point it
has to turn people into like we support
this purge but then if you get if you
get I guess purged out you're going to
be like I don't support this if if
literally everything is taken from you
almost in one night which is what I
assume this this kind of last comment
was of like you can this whole night you
can be supportive of it but if it comes
to you a thing that like you think will
never happen you're like or your
neighborhood tune might be changing
there was so many different twists and
turns and red herrings in this like you
think about the boyfriend
at the beginning didn't end up coming
back or you think about when they let in
that
stranger but he isn't the the downfall
of them although had they never opened
their doors to him he would have died
but the family would have lived um but
you thought when he first let him in I
was super suspicious of him like oh he's
pretending to be hurt in the street to
come in me too but he wasn't they did a
really good job with all of that and
then finally showing us we think we know
with all the rich kids and then it's the
neighbors your own neighbors who turn on
you who just brought you [__] cookies
yeah that was really it was it was every
time I think I had it I didn't have it
yeah me neither that was really good it
was awesome I mean I loved the dialogue
the writing was great I mean as you said
the story is awesome but also her for
Lena's I forget what her character name
is but for her like Dark Knight of the
Soul kind of mostly happened with her
going what are you doing what are we
doing here and it's it's almost that
Ethan Hawk dying is like that sucks
right because he's just was trying to be
a good dad and a husband and keep his
kids safe but he never had that like
Soul moment he just was constantly going
no let's just get him out of here I
don't care if we kill this guy um and it
was nice to see that they had written in
for Lena's character the mom character
of her her switch of like we can't do
this he and oh he did he was like we're
going to fight you're right uh his
daughter his daughter looks at him and
says it will never be okay again look at
what you're doing it'll never be fine I
think he did have it that the moment to
me the biggest foreshadowing is when
Ethan Hawk looks at the guy who came in
and said you're gonna die tonight one
way or another yeah either like a man
walk out there and do it or um they're
going to come in and kill my kids too
and finally the guy says bring me out
there and that's when Ethan decides not
to to fight because I guess if you're
going to go with your own logic of be a
man then you [__] be a man and fight
like you know and he does and then the
not the joke of it all but he's the one
who ends up dead not the guy he's the
only one who ends up dead in the family
right yeah I feel like I guess the the
soul moment I I blanked for a moment
that I was like yeah he did get them all
together and be like we're going to
fight is because Lena's character really
like spoke to it the most and I really
liked her saying that of like what are
we doing we can't do this and then her
even growing more into that especially
at the end of like there won't be any
more killing like her her making a
choice for there to be peace for the
rest of the night even though these
people were ready to stab them her and
all of her kids for this purge nonsense
that's crazy to me it's cool
generationally that we're wa when you're
watching this and the two kids like we
just talked about you just talked about
the term of Ethan the turn of Lena and
the kids are the ones who are like this
is [__] wrong yeah the daughter and
the son and it's because you're not born
with these biases these prejudices these
this evil you're not born with that it
it develops and it's a learned behavior
right it's a learned behavior to hate
people based on how much money they have
the color of their skin their age their
size whatever the [__] it is right and
so the fact that we do see them like
that but then we're seeing that the kids
coming for the purge and her boyfriend
already have that hate in them that
probably comes from their parents right
that probably comes from their
upbringing how they were raised whatever
it is yeah super [__] interesting to
watch and to see that the the kids are
the ones that are are able to get to
their parents like or especially their
dad yeah that this is wrong it does set
it up where it's like the morally that
family did have it on on a right on the
right spectrum of like we have morals
here but he was put in a tough position
when the when the guy initially came in
so I understand why he was doing that
but I still was upset that he didn't
that the kid noticed like I feel like
the kid notic the tags like was the
first one that they wouldn't look at the
tags and be like why don't you just help
us like get out of this I I would have I
would I mean he did eventually but not
really they didn't release him he got
out on his own and I would have really
liked to just see the family go we're
not going to sorry we I'm sorry I
stabbed you a couple of times and then
tied you up but and then pushed on it
yeah like my God I was like I'd be like
let's try and tape this wound up and
let's all try to just survive the night
together what do you think the main
message of the movie is if you had to
like put it into a sentence what do you
think the message
is and which is so weird of me to ask
you after we just watched The Purge
because I did not think this was going
to be a message oriented movie like I
thought it was going to be a horror like
Halloween or like Friday 13th or
whatever I did not think this was going
to be as thematically interesting as it
was not that those other movies aren't
great but right I mean it's like the
class system sucks and they did a really
nice job of highlighting that the
reasoning of the people at the end of
going they're not theirs you're ours now
and the reason we're killing you is
because you're flaunting your money in
our face and yet they all have an
abundance of it it's like that's what's
getting to people in in the upper
echelon of society right it's like all
right we're going to purge you now
because you you added an add-on and we
couldn't do that um it's so trivial it
makes it to where you're putting these
uh the the upper class Society into this
like tiny little box with these trivial
little things and they lose so much
sight of what is right and what's wrong
and I mean we did luckily you know
running into Ethan and Lena their their
family did have a little bit of what's
right and what's wrong in the beginning
they lost sight of it but we got them
back and that was good um so I don't I
don't know ex I think it's maybe just
class system sucks and there's a lot of
trivial things when you when you really
look at it people have a lot of money
lose sight of what's I feel like
actually important CU like why why also
was the kids that are like this swine of
a homeless person deserves to be killed
by us this is all just setting up get
out our anger yeah a class of system of
like you're not worthy and I'm like he
fought for the country that you live in
now this is how all for your freedom to
do this exactly I think that the the
main message is not that you
asked what do you
think
per I think the main message is that um
no one person's life is more important
than another person's life right like no
matter any of the things and and this
movie really hits that home especially
at the end with her not having him
[__] blast them um and I can't even
lie at that point I would I would said
[__] well you said blast him four times
I think yeah because you guys all were
trying to kill us and at the end of the
day life is unbelievably important it
matters and we're only each given one
and the when you don't treat other
people like their life matters as much
as yours because we were all lucky
enough to be born then you lose sight of
everything if you don't believe
everybody around you's life is as
important as yours for whatever reason
then you're [__] yeah I agree and I
mean I guess that's like a another a
huge thing that they they highlight here
that it does send a message that there
are real people like that that don't
taken it's just if you live in a crappy
house in a poor neighborhood you are
less than than me and you are not you're
not living up to the standards of what I
deem to be a human if you're like a rich
person in this movie which is sad yeah
what did you think about the the
combination of the way that it was shot
for the majority of the time but then
with like the camera I'm going to call
it ring cam obviously that's not what it
was at this time but just all and then
the robot camera did you like how we had
a bunch of different kinds of camera
shots I feel like we did because the the
POV like the the handheld camera always
felt like it to me was in the POV of
like what the purge is now bringing like
the POV of The Purge coming up on you
versus in the beginning setting up the
town we still had some Dolly and
tracking shots like smoother shots and
uh uh and then just yeah towards the end
using the um when we saw the people
outside we really only saw them from the
security camera's point of view until
they came inside which I thought was a a
fun way to do it because we just we
stayed in that POV of like the house and
what they're
experiencing um and I like that because
they could have sure shown shown them
from the security footage and then cut
to actually them outside and what's
going on and where they're sitting what
are they talking about we didn't need it
I like them utilizing that footage of No
Talking they're spread out you just see
them waiting around with their weapons
it kind of was a nice way to build up
tension yeah I completely agree and then
also I feel like other than the shots as
two actresses here I think it'd be crazy
for us to not to talk a little bit about
these effing performances because as we
were going throughout it it's like no
[__] Ethan Hawk and Lena HEI are going
to be yeah them great I mean they were
phenomenal but then their two kids
really nailed it the guy who comes into
the house who we are immediately
suspicious of that's all in his eyes and
the
dude fire I was just like wow each one
of you guys I I wonder what this casting
process was like because obviously I'm
assuming that Ethan and Lena well
actually what year was this that that
I'm thinking Lena got offer so yeah that
would have been in the height of
probably Game of Thrones time right a
little bit still I think so so I would
say no mudy little bit it's the
beginning yeah yeah the beginning yeah
2013 so I would say that probably Ethan
gets this straight offer maybe she
auditioned but she must have smoked
everybody cuz she was so good and these
other people were did you know them at
all like they're unknowns to not at all
for them to like be at Ethan's caliber I
was like wow that's really impressive
yeah I thought the only weird Choice
which I also liked it was the neighbor
the blonde annoying lady that it was
like she was so robotic but I know it
was a choice of like she's weird there's
something off here um yeah yeah but then
you know what was interesting I'm so
with you that that was weird but when
she comes at the end because of her
choices I thought I'm being such a dick
judging a book by its cover in terms of
like she was this white blonde girl who
shows up with cookies and already I'm
like [__] creepy and I was like why
Rox like we just learned don't judge a
book by its cover she's come to save
them be on her side and then it was like
nope [__] we're flipping again yeah oh
God it it was so great when especially
when you see the two neighbors I was
like there's still something weird here
where they shoot the people off and they
don't ask Lena if she's okay they just
like move on and I'm like this is
something weird is going on here uh but
yeah I like the setup that initially we
we felt like something was a little
off-kilter with her and then especially
at the end the way she spoke it's like
you're going to Stepford wi land very
satisfying to see her nose get bashed
that that was so great and to see Lena
do that herself she'd need her backup
right is so great and he just and and I
agree with um the casting for him which
I I mean he didn't have a name military
guys is what I kept calling him is that
um what do they call him the credit
stranger something I don't know bloody
stranger I think they called him think
oh boy well I'm going to look up on IMDb
what actually his his thing is yeah yeah
I feel like in his eyes but especially
just like him you could just feel he had
a heart and like uh he he had a right
versus wrong and he felt very defeated
um in the beginning he was fighting for
his life which yeah I I would too listen
I'm not going to die tonight I'm not
here to hurt you guys but please don't
send me out there um okay so Edwin Hodge
played bloody stranger that is his name
in his bloody Str oh and he's from
Mayan's the Kurt Suter show after uh
Sons of Anarchy he's been in a lot of
different stuff his his whole vibe in
this movie of saying everything without
saying a
word really good stuff really good uh
wow a lot of these people work a ton so
yeah and then that guy Rees Wakefield is
the blonde dude dude he was so effing
creepy oh and he shares a birthday with
my mom oh he was on True Detective oh I
love that show all right well I'm going
to look more into them you ever see
somebody that you're like wow you're
very good and then you you star them or
heart them on you favorite them on IMDb
and you just like start watching their
work like that this oh totally and then
you look you're like oh they've been
working all of their lives they're like
they've been working since they were
four yeah all right damn it's amazing
and that's gonna be us one day until
then The Purge any other final baby I
would rate I I mean this movie to me I
I'm I'll give it like an
8.5 I really I really I really enjoyed
it and and it was short and sweet not
sweet short short and good yeah really
good grounded well done performances and
the writing the story I love the writing
the writing and the story really great
the only thing that made me mad is that
they didn't untie military guy and ask
him to fight along with him but it it
added for a Twist at the end where he
pops up but I was yeah and there was a
lot of popups at the end but I liked
every one of them horror often times has
[__] dialogue I've noticed that it feels
forced and weird this didn't it felt
like the characters were developed uh
even if you didn't like them at times it
was like yeah that is a brat teenage
girl that's what they're like bro
exactly I've been there and I was like
oh she's so annoying and then I was like
oh actually see myself in
her what a bummer uh okay so That's The
Purge and I'm going to be brainstorming
what I would Purge until the next time
is there a sequel to this I don't know
you would think so right as a premise
you could do this over and over and over
again right I would be interested to see
if they choose to just follow one family
or now choose to follow multiple people
along the course of a Purge Night
imagine being a shop owner no I would I
would uh just lock it up and go yeah
this year I have my I have my shop for a
good 8 n 10 months cuz it's going to
take me 3 months to rebuild and then
every year I got to start over again cuz
the purge is coming it's just like a
diamond
store like you just can't take your
diamonds home put them in your pockets
or saer in your pockets shove them up my
Cooter and be like well they got to come
for me before they get the diamonds you
heard it here first guys and gals and
people at home Tara's going to shove the
diamonds up her cter on that note thank
you like comment subscribe give us all
that love we'll Purge with you later
later with all the diamonds that got in
our bloodstream okay bye
[Music]
bye